Tenerife residents can do little but
watches the worst blaze in four decades
threatens the north of the Spanish
Island
wildfires began earlier this week in a
mountainous National Park in the center
of the island
the fires have laid waste to more than 5
000 hectares of land within a 50
kilometer radius
no homes have yet been destroyed
residents are appealing to Emergency
Services to do everything in their power
to keep it that way
the fire is near the farm we have a
truck a van the farmlands and all our
hens are there everything it's a
business that was doing well but the
fire could completely ruin us please do
something about it because the fires are
right there
they're worried about the animals
they've Left Behind
the firemen are in front of the houses
we want them to stay there so that the
fire doesn't go to the homes and maybe
some of our animals can be saved we are
as you can understand nervous
thousands have been evacuated but not
everyone is taking up the offer of
temporary accommodation
we are staying in the car they offered
us a place at a sports center down there
but we prefer to stay in the car because
that way we can watch if the house burns
or not
smoke is hampering efforts to battle The
Blaze from the air but authorities say
they are working to bring the wildfires
threatening 11 towns under control
Mike lepple Al Jazeera
foreign